the two pictures who are these two
pictures this is the pictures of emma
barnett's
mother and father to his neighbors the
rolls-royce driving businessman
seemed to be a respectful and successful
member of the community
but in reality ian barnett 59 had
had made a fortune from running a string
of brothels a court heard yesterday
any uh female imams are there yeah so
the question i'm asking emma here is
emma can you answer the question please
please answer the question how many
prostitutes
women who are selling their bodies in
your mom and in your dad's
brothels how many was there can you
please answer the question the word
oppressed
and using the words how many female
imams
zero female imams zero how many
prostitutes in the brothels many
many less prior to ourselves inshallah
very important police discovered that
fought
that a photograph of her posted on the
internet to advertise her service had
been taken by a camera
assalamu alaikum welcome to a better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are on the show
now this topic has been discussed vastly
by many people in different channels
and i uh and recently muhammad miami
have done a video on it as well and we
discussed it in depth and
it was done and dusted and i don't find
it repetitive just do do one on my
channel for the sake of it yeah okay
um but however i was scrolling and i
found a comment
and i was like hold on a second emma
barnett's dad was a pimp
he owned profiles he's like yo that
sounds deep and there's
that's actually profound why is it
profound because the way she bullied a
muslim sister
i would like to interrogate her now i
know she
sometimes says she was doing a job no no
i saw that outright bullying
now here's the article let's read it for
ourselves and sisters yeah okay
daily fail as you guys know uh yeah now
during my glasses what i'm reading okay
6.2 6.2 million
fortune of of brothel baron funded a
lavish house
cars and even a thousand pounds number
plate
yeah okay and these are the two pictures
who are these two pictures this is the
pictures of emma barnett's
mother and father to his neighbors the
rolls-royce driving businessman
seemed to be a respectful and successful
member of the community
but in reality ian barnett 59 had
had made a fortune from running a string
of brothels at court heard yesterday
he and his wife michelle 58 was said to
have earned
6.2 million
yep million from the chain of sex pilots
now in this country that's illegal yeah
to have you know ruffles as far as i'm
legal as soon as you pay your taxes
it's okay you know um and all the other
mad stuff that happens
alhamdulillah islam has come to honor a
woman yeah to
help her the state has to help her just
so that she doesn't have to feel that
she has to go
and sell her body to fund a lavish
lifestyle or today's time some people
have to pay the university fees you've
got girls who are doing strip
um work in strip clubs and even brothels
and selling their body
to pay for their your tuition fees
this is the state that we live in yeah
but it's okay as long as you pay your
taxes to the government
long live the queen let's carry on ian
barney who lived in a half a million
house in prest press witch with his wife
michelle pictured admitted keeping a
string of brothels
in 2008. he was in court today to
consent a proceeds
at crime up court such was their success
that along with
her 20 000 x-type jaguar and his
rolls-royce with its 40 000 pounds
personalized number plate
they had a half a million pound house in
an exclusive neighborhood
the empire finally came crashing down
what goes up it must come down if it's
especially if it's haram
when barnett was jailed for controlling
prostitution
and yesterday he was back in court as
the authorities sought to recover his
alleged
ill-gotten gains barnett was given a
three-year sentence in 2008 for keeping
four brothels in and around manchester
with names such as dolly mixtures
foreign touch and angels foreign touch
yes we call it haram touch anyways the
trial judge branded him an evil
immoral man saying he has conducted his
vile trait on a
breath taking scale he and his wife had
lived in a comfortable detached house in
nearby press
which we but moved to another property
in the area following his release
halfway through his jail term
yesterday a procedure of crime cons
confiscation hearing was thought of the
vast sums of money bond
bonnet allegedly generated through his
illicit business detective constable
john turner from the financial
investigation unit of greater manchester
police said
job sheets found that the brothers
showed how much each each
brought in per month yeah
okay and by the way guys let's bear in
mind this is this is uh emma barnett who
is questioning a muslim woman
why are there no female imams why are
there no feminine men
yes but why are they not female imams i
think the question that needs to be
asked here emma
is you know um how many prostitutes
how many women were working in these
brothels selling their bodies
sexualized yes as um as um
being sexualized objectified selling
their body
yeah so the question i'm asking am i
here is emma can you answer the question
please
please
answer the question how many prostitutes
women
who are selling their bodies in your mom
and in your dad's
brothels how many was there can you
please answer the question the word
oppressed
and using the word slate maybe okay you
may not know the numbers but you know
still you know we need to you know we
need to ask the question you know can
you you know maybe in the rough figure
of how many prostitutes were working for
your mom and dad
illegally you know it's not even legal
it's fun it was illegally
i'm not coming and saying emma is
directly involved in this and she
condones that no
but what i'm trying to say is get your
priorities right because a female imam
a a female not being an imam in a mosque
is in no way she performed harming her
it doesn't cause her to sell a body it
doesn't cause her to be sexually
objectified at all
it doesn't let's carry on reading
anyways clients would be charged 40
pounds an hour with 25 pounds going to
the prostitution and the remainder to
bind it
barnett had been arrested after a
lithuanian teenager known as rita was
illegally smuggled into the country
okay guys check this out barnett her dad
had been arrested after a lutheran
lithuanian
teenage teenager known as rita was
illegally
smuggled sex trafficking into the
country by an albanian
gang and ended up working at one of his
brothels can you imagine
these people are kidnapping blackmailing
these
teenage girls bringing them to the
country these gangs
selling them like a piece of meat here
you go there's a piece of me there you
go
here you go yes yes it's just a book
there you go take it yeah
and now force her because she probably
knows if her family's that death threat
or whatever you have to now sell your
body
do all kinds of sex acts and what is
this issue willingly apparently
sick sell your body do all kinds of
sexual acts disgusting
to men who are coming to pay for a
service they're paying for your body
here you go there's my money i'll do
whatever i like to yes i'm going to do
whatever i like to
um can you imagine the disgust you know
and you're here questioning the muslim
woman about imams
yeah the imams and how many how many
female imams
zero female imams zero how many
prostitutes in the brothels many
many less prior to ourselves in china
very important so as you can see guys
imagine
hundreds or thousands of your six to
make 6.2 million pounds
you're talking hundreds or thousands of
girls maybe most of them are sex
trafficked
kidnapped or whatever blackmail to come
to this country
and to sell their self brothers and
sisters nothing else needs to be said
i think that was a big snap in the face
to somebody who is a feminist who's a
woman
in woman's hour as a liberal
questioning and humiliating a muslim
woman about female imams
whereas her mom and her dad and i'm not
saying she's to blame this is a matter
of priority
was too busy um selling girls that are
kidnapped in lithuania our teenage girls
came up to lutheran lithuania to come
and sell their bodies
in the united kingdom yeah so guys
i think this is a good message out there
pleased to share it with uh emma
barnett i would like to know her
response to this inshallah and she
should prioritize
stopping this because it's very close to
home till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh